even with the on-demand economy you
click a button a car shows up sometimes
I could be dehumanizing to the workers
too right we've built all these pregnant
products and services for these top 1
percenters living in urban centers like
san francisco in new york and the point
is almost minimize human connection hit
a button leave the package there go away
don't bother me you know it's almost
like factoring out human connection and
so if technology 1.0 was all about this
drive towards more convenience less
friction it's created this abundance
reality we have which i think is making
us very unhappy because now we have more
content than you consume in a lifetime
more games and any one person could ever
play more calories and anyone treat them
rightly or healthily consumed in a day
you know all this stuff that is
available to us now this abundance of
choices which actually creates a lot of
stress because our brains still have the
neural programming of when we're running
around the steps of Africa and and and
just trying to survive in a threat build
scarcity environment that's why our
tongue see calorie dense foods our eyes
are looking for novelty our minds are
always looking for simple heuristic
causal narratives we're looking for
anything that gives us an edge for
procreation that almost explains any
humans behavior in any one moment does
this help me procreate don't get eaten
eat and pass on my genes right and so
we've got that scarcity mindset but now
it's living in this like huge abundance
filled you know choice cornucopia and
the two don't match that impedance
mismatch is driving us literally crazy
we're low batting our biology and our no
programming to that get through each day
hence we need things like fasting and we
need tech Shabbat sand we need you know
anti-tech addiction and we have open we
need more mindfulness because you're
basically trying to curb our impulses in
this sort of candy store of infinite
choices right
I feel like modern people it's like
you're it's like you're you're a crack
addict and you've been handed a crack
pipe with the administer plies okay
self-regulate right so maybe tech 2.0 is
about helping us manage those impulses
and become better people the people we
want to be you know starting with more
reduction with ourselves and each other
but also maybe limiting some of these
impulses may be reducing choice may be
reducing the need for so much willpower
maybe even you know reducing friction
and convenience you know people think
I'm nuts when I say that but I wonder if
the next act of technology is
introducing more helpful friction or
intentional you know inconvenience to
make us more reconnected with ourselves
with supply chain with each other with
mother nature with where things come
from you know because you know isn't
that that saying you really care about
what you have to work for right and um I
was talking to Tom Qi the other day you
know he came from Google actually had
this really great point that we're
living in an age where everything is so
well curated you know events and
settings and whatnot and it's all made
for Instagram ability right so it looks
all great but combine that with
convenient this is all about it looks
great I didn't have to do anything for
it but I worry that that creates this
sugar-coated surface that it had doesn't
have meaning you know so I guess
sometimes I go to events or festivals
everything's so well curated
I didn't have to lift a finger and it's
all about like a huh get myself here
just right and I forget I've even been
there after a month as opposed to you
really have to work at something when
you have to sync blood sweat and tears
into it that investment creates this
emotional true connection with it
creates meaning increased purpose and so
I'm wondering if that's what we've
siphoned out of a lot of our experiences
is that investment that work that we
have to put into something to derive
that meaning and purpose which flies in
the face of instant gratification
convenience